pendant le trajet vers Calvi le prêtre
se met sous la protection du ciel avec
une prière Corse bien
singulière commencement de cette route
élo de nous les dangers les chauffards
les gendarmes donous d'arriver à bon
port à la bonne heure en bon état et
d'avoir des paroles de charité pour le
coup du silence
amenen juste mon père si je peux me
permettre pouro voulez gendarme parce
que vous avez pas le permis c'est ça
vous avez pardon excusez-moi ça me
démanger oh moi je voulais le faire mais
moi aussi je savais pas
comment frère Baudoin euh fait une
prière dit j'espère qu'on ne va pas
avoir d'accident mon Dieu je prie et
qu'on ne rencontre pas de gendarmes et
là c'est Simon qui a dit mais euh maises
frères